come everybody who of you has
source oh that's nice okay and who of
you has done this using git okay that's
right the most of you most of the time
and it's not primarily before open
source usage if we're using git we can
use git but we can do it in a way that's
not very nice and and what I'm trying to
do in this talk is to to look at the
technical parts of git but from an angle
of ur of an use case perspective how to
behave in the right way when I'm when
I'm using it but first things first
my name is Sebastian I'm working neck
tract check 24 here in Germany I'm doing
programming for roughly 30 years now so
I started with a c64 and some basic and
moved from there I'm doing some open
source mostly in the web PHP area and
like most people I say stupid stuff on
the internet so if you care you can you
can follow me on Twitter anybody has
seen something similar like like this
right yeah I'm not swearing onstage so
I'm not reading out loud what's
happening here but this is a commit
history I see in a lot of projects it
doesn't help you at all
figuring out what's happening in your
software and and figuring out what's
happening in your software is is quite
important and it's it's especially
important for for open source of them so
the first concept I want to talk about
our atomic commits and so what are
atomic commits so if you see a commit
message like this implementing new
voting feature fixed an internal
messaging issue and refactor some
inheritance menís great right and
there's way too much going on there
and that's basically not what atomic
commit means and atomic commit would be
much more like this right we would say
add voting persistent service refactor
for motorists to be composable fixed
internal messaging issue and add voting
API endpoints and actions and this has a
lot of advantages if we do it this way
for one if somebody needs this fix he
can just cherry-pick this commit if you
buried this fix somehow it anywhere in
this in the commit over there he's not
able to get the fix so then you start
copy pasting stuff and sending patches
and yeah it's getting really messy but
if you if you do it in an atomic way you
can just push it upstream and somebody
can cherry-pick your fix and that's
that's quite nice another thing is and
that's where it's becoming important for
for the development process if you're
doing pull requests or code reviews so
who's doing pull requests or code
reviews on a regular basis yeah right
okay cool so especially if you
contribute stuff in open source you're
doing pull requests and somebody has to
figure out what you've done and has to
understand what you've done with the
software and imagine one commit so you
see a pull request like this there's one
commit 17 files changed and that's not
very big right so it's it's still small
but if you look at the pull request and
you see 17 files change you have no idea
where to start right it's it's becoming
this big mess and like I said 17 files
is really small and even that's horrible
to to to review right so if you like
have 50 files change or 80 it's it's a
total disaster what happens if you do
this in an atomic way and doing atomic
commit
you still have in the end 80 files
changed but you have these anchor points
of your of your thinking process but you
can say okay I first did this and then I
did that and then I did something else
and what somebody can do is he can click
on every commit and can watch or can
check the files that changed for each
commit and then he can follow your
thinking process much easier he can say
oh ok that's what he did to change the
persistence layer okay that's totally
clear because he had to add some data
access objects and that's that's totally
fine for me okay that's five files and
then you go to the next commit and see
okay he added some API endpoints okay
therefore you should add some
controllers and actions okay next six
files check done right so it's it's much
easier if you if you keep the commits
and and do very small commits and of
course Master Oogway has some rules for
atomic commits atomic commits are a
single irreducible but useful set of
changes and that's very important
they're useful because I what I hear
often is yeah I like I read this blog
post and they said commit often commit
always and that's right
but then your commit history is like a
safe game in a computer game like it's
quick safe quick load quick safe quick
quick load and none of your quicksaves
matter for me so it doesn't really have
has anything meaningful in it so you can
do this
but in the end if you submit the pull
request or get to the point where you
get a code review please clean up that
mess and create single useful set of
changes next one is everything works and
that's that's really really important
you can commit as much crap as you want
please if you submit a pull request make
it that every come
is deployable to production so I can
choose any commit in the commit history
and deploy it to production that makes
it much easier for everybody to work
with with the software because everybody
knows I can use any set or any commit in
my history and deploy it to production
and it should work like I said it
doesn't have to work in your in your
daily work so you can commit but before
you submit the pull request or stuff
like that you can clean that up and I
will show you in a second how it's done
mmm and a rule of thumb is don't use the
end words in commit messages right so if
there's an end then it's already too
much so don't do that and so when I'm
talking about commit messages I was
really relieved that the previous
speaker didn't go into detail about
commit messages because yeah then this
would be kind of yeah you're 11 now but
who knows this website what the commits
calm okay
not so many that's nice so if you ever
need for a cool handy commit message
right and you don't know what to do what
do you I go just go to what the commits
come and you get some gems like major
fix up fixed to pure one that not simply
merged into master and one of my
absolute favorites is best commit ever
so obviously those are fun but as we
seen before they are not very useful so
once again must agree has some some
rules for us how we should should do
commit messages and the first one is
separate the the subject and the body
with a blank line and when I tell people
this they look at me funny and say
a commit message body doesn't have a
commit message only for words or
something like that yeah we will see an
example later limits a subject to 50
characters that's we will see why this
is a bit of important in a second don't
end the subject with a period um yeah
this more arbitrary but so since we're
limiting us to 15 characters every
character counts so don't waste it for a
point or for a period next one
capitalize the subject line and that's
yeah it's kind of the same I'm kind of a
strange person if I see a get history
and the first word starting with upper
case lower case upper case lower case
lower case then it convinces me out but
that's I'm special in that way so I
always try to bring people to the point
where you can see okay yeah just
capitalize them and that's a lot more
important use the imperative mood for
commit messages and the imperative mood
is it is as the former I say it's do it
so it's not
I fixed issue number 500 or something
like this it's fix issue and we see a
good examples in a second next one is
wrap the body at 72 characters and
that's mostly for terminal nerds like me
that are not using any GUI tools we are
very happy if we don't have to side
scroll for your commit messages and last
one is use the body to explain what and
why versus how because how you did
something
the code is telling me that I know how
you achieved your your changes but I
don't know why you did it and what was
the intent of that that change so maybe
you ever
a situation where you where somebody
asks you hey why did we change that and
you say I don't know the commit message
chef we change it yeah but but why it's
a completely different thing so it's
quite nice to keep track of stuff like
that in in commit messages but let's go
back to the subject line so if you have
a commit message and it's longer than 50
characters most tools like github get
lap or bit pockets are shortening your
your commit message and most of the time
when I see this
it's okay yada yada yada yadi and the
important saving is dot dot dot crap
like right the the important stuff is
always hidden behind the dots so I
always have to to click so yeah just
keep the very important stuff in in
fifty characters then we said use the
imperative mood and it's we're just
following the example of get because git
is doing exactly that it's it's not
saying we are merging branch my feature
it says merge branch so we should always
do as git does so and there's a there's
a good rule of thumb you can use this
sentence if applied this commit will and
then use the use your commit message
title or subject and if you have some
some bad examples so if applied this
commit will fixed but okay that's sounds
strange and the good example is this
commit will merge branch fix this commit
will update the getting started
documentation this will this will and
it's in the beginning it's it's awkward
to write commit messages like this at
least it was for me but you get commit
messages get very precise if you're
using the imperative
so I can only encourage you to to do
that and a complete example could could
look like this
you have the subject then the blank line
and the body right and of course yes not
not every commit message has to look
this way right but especially if you if
you keep atomic commits and if you merge
into a master and you squash all your
atomic commits together then the merge
commit should look like this it should
be a real combination of all the commit
messages that were squished together
have you ever seen some stuff like that
in your on your projects or your go to
GUI tool and you want to look what's
happening in your branches and you're
looking at the get graph and at that
point it's no longer get graph it's like
a git hero thing and yeah so it must
agree has something to sell out a tell
about them so he says your mind is like
the get graph my friend when it is
agitated it becomes difficult to see but
if you allow it to settle the answer
becomes clear and what that means is if
you have a get graph like that and you
can get to it very very easily you it's
it's totally useless you know it doesn't
help you anymore and the get graph can
be very very useful but for that you
have to follow some some some guidelines
so why is your get graph messed up like
this and it's messed up because you're
doing merges and if you're doing merges
get always keeps track of something
where it came from and where it's going
and if you merge a lot then you get
graph becomes like yeah like this guitar
hero thing
so merging is safe it's the safest way
to to to get stuff together but it
messes up the history a bit right so why
is that so if we look at a git merge so
we have a feature branch and if nothing
changes we can do this fast-forward
merge right so it's we just get our get
on new commits in and everything is fine
but if we have something happening in
the master branch in the meantime then
kid has to kind of yeah I have to get do
some guesswork here right so I'm
guessing oh this should work but just to
be sure I'm creating this merge commit
and thus merge commit is actually really
really handy because as I said this is
kind of guesswork
what get is doing and it's really good
in it but it still can cause problems
and this merge commit is handy in a way
that you can if you are undoing this
merge commit then the right ones are
gone as well so if you undo the merge
all commits that you merged with this
merge are gone as well so it's very easy
to undo merges but how can we do this in
a nicer way right
so since merge commits and merges are
kind of messing up our history so what
we can we do and the answer to this is
rebasing and who of you is rebasing on a
regular basis like daily okay get put a
tree base right okay what rebasing does
is it actually and I heard a lot of
people saying no no no we did we base
once and it was a disaster
everything went to hits right and
why was that because what get is doing
is it just it's not throwing your
commits away but it's just removing your
commits and storing them somewhere and
then it's it's getting the latest
changes and then it's reapplying your
commits and it is it was subtle in in
the slides but as you can see that the
color has has changed for before the
commits were read and now the dots are
purple and that's because it's those
aren't completely new commits so what
you've done is you've changed the
history and that's the dangerous stuff
in and get right so we and that's why
everybody's talking about never rebase
master or never rebased shared branches
and stuff like this because what you
what you're creating when you when
you're pushing or force pushing this you
you could can create a little a big mess
for for other people with with that code
but in our situation this now is really
nice because forget now it is that we
started at this point we started our
work at this point and now we can again
create these this fast-forward merge and
we don't have a merge commit and that's
that's quite nice cool so now we have a
very clean history but this causes a
problem so now if we want to undo the
merge we are we have no idea how many
commits we merged right so now it's easy
because okay that we have the two purple
ones but what if you merged like 30
commits or something like this you have
no idea how much you really merge and if
you want to undo it you have to turn
that go back like 29 commits or whether
it's 30 or what at 31 and it's always
one more too much or so it you got
doing this you cannot make this right so
what we are doing is we still are
merging but what we are doing now is we
are forcing it to create a merge commit
and now you're saying okay Sebastian but
you said much commits are bad yes if
you're doing merges all over the place
but if you're doing it this way what
you're ending up with is something like
this and this is really really nice you
have a clean history and you always
branch and then we turn to the master so
this is your this is your master right
and you always can see okay we did this
feature we get the green feature then we
did the blue bug fix and then the purple
feature and stuff like that and if you
if you messed up the integration you can
just undo the merge commit and all the
commits that came with that merge are
gone so if you have so I always say
start with the simplest workflow or git
workflow you can if you start developing
a project and this is quite simple I
would say but now you get graph is very
useful you can see what's happening in
your project right it will always stay
only two lines it's never going wider
than two lines if you if you are doing
this mmm
you can do some funny stuff you don't
have to read this but we were talking a
bit about git alias a bit more in a
second but what you can do is you can
create aliases that support your work
flowing it so this is a good alias that
I called integrate and what it does is
it tries to merge a branch but it it
checks if it can fast-forward merge it
in if so it
just it with a merge commit and if it
can merge it fast-forward it will say no
no you have to rebase the the branch
first so this is a really nice way of
helping you doing that stuff that seems
a little bit more complicated in the
first place but as I I said rebasing can
be dangerous and you should remember
that please please don't do it on share
branches so if you're working on your
future branch and you're working on it
completely alone it's completely fine
you can rebase however you want it but
as soon as somebody else is working on
that code please don't just rebase if
you have to please talk to the person
that or to the people that are using the
this branch as well and if you have a
workflow where you create branches of
branches don't ever rebase because you
have no idea if somebody is using your
branch to create another branch and if
you rebase that that's totally horrible
for everybody who who branched off of
your branch that's so a rule of thumb
please don't create branches or feature
branches if ever possible don't don't do
that
so what does the good students do the
good we right commit message that are
precise and informative and we create a
mess by committing often but before we
before we create pull requests or go to
a code review we clean it up and so how
do we clean it up so the people who are
using rebase on a daily basis already
know so
we're starting with git rebase - I for
the interactive rebase and what that
does is it shows us a list of commits
that we did in in our development
process and now we have as you can see
we have four commits in here and it is
very nice it's already giving us some
options and in telling us what we what
we can do with with those commit and for
example we can just move the line and
say okay this fixed typo belongs to the
superhero fighting skills it wasn't a
typo for the public API it was a typo in
the fighting skills so we move it up and
what we can do now is we can say okay
I don't want anybody to know that I'm a
bad typer
so these fixed typo commits it should
disappear nobody needs to know that so
what we can do is we can change pick to
fix up here and what that will do is it
will combine the second and now the
third commit together so the changes
will be combined but the commit message
will the fixed type of commit message is
gone so let's fix up and you can squash
commit that's quite that's the same
thing but now it will ask you what kind
of commit message you want to you want
to use and give you the ability to edit
the commit message again you can go
crazy and do use edit then the rebase
will stop and you can go back to the
terminal add files or do more changes
and really edit the commit but in in
most cases you're really fine with
changing the order and doing fix ups or
squashes and that's most of the time the
only thing you have to do right
combining stuff and changing the order
to make it to make it understandable and
clean so we save and now
the rebase went then through and if we
look at our get lock now we can see that
the fixed type of Comet is gone right
and nobody will ever know that you
mistyped that's that's really nice and
it's not only that nobody knows that you
don't don't type very good they all it's
it's useless information for everybody
out there so nobody cares that that you
fix the typo so they they yeah of course
they care but it's it's not very useful
information and it's not helping them in
any way to understand what's happening
in your repository so you can easily get
rid of those commits and now we have
this problem since I've said okay if we
do a rebase so what we're doing is we're
creating new comets right so we throw
commits away and we creating new new
ones and especially if you squash them
or maybe you you accidentally said you
don't need that commit at all and that
was a mistake so now you you're in a
state where you can say okay that's not
really good because it's gone
right and that's weather where you
normally do a - RF and remove the
repository and clone it again and do all
your day's work again yeah no more
because there's the ref lock ref lock to
the rescue what the refuge is giving you
is if you execute gif ref lock command
the ref dog is actually a more detailed
history you don't only have the commits
as a history the the ref lock has a much
more detailed history and as you can see
in this example we have like when we we
have a lock entry where we started the
rebase and then we have
we have an lock entry where we did this
fix-up thing and combined two commits
and even one where everything whether
whether rebase is done and we can now go
back to each of those states right you
can they okay we can completely go back
before our rebase and then everything is
back to the state where where we started
rebasing so if you completely mess up
it's not a problem
the ref lock can can help you so what
you do is you just say okay I want to go
to this position of the ref lock in our
cases had four headed for and then
you're back at that state right and
you're in our case I think that's before
we started the rebase so you you can
retry to rebase it in a the right way in
this case right and now that we we based
and made everything clean and nice
of course we have to force push right
and that's scary because we can do a lot
of harm with with force pushing and that
speak because there's force with lease
and what that's doing it gives you a
small safety net because if you're
pushing with false beliefs it will not
override commits in a central repository
that you that you don't know of so if
somebody changed your branch in the
meantime while your rebasing then
they're in the central repository
there's a commit that you don't know of
and then it will tell you and say no no
you can't force push because somebody
changed the repository already you have
to do something differently now right so
you have to rebase a gown or whatever
right this prevents a lot of angry
colleagues coming after you with
pictures and forks
yeah throwing stuff at you so that's
basically the the behavioral part right
how we should behave and now to get some
to make this all a little bit easier I
want to share some some tips and tricks
you can use to make it to get handling a
little bit more easy and one of the
first things I do when I configure a new
machine is I set up my kid aliases and
you can do a lot of crazy stuff with kid
aliases for example like yeah I already
told you I'm not good at typing so I'm
most of the time I'm using one character
commands like get get P for Paul get C
for commit or get B for branch like yeah
you have no idea how much I miss type
git status so I'm doing good workshops
as well so it's always funny and then
I'm not using my aliases because that
would be kind of weird for everybody if
I only type GS or something like that
but if we would make a drinking game
whenever I miss type status we won't get
out of the workshop a life so yeah just
remember don't get too crazy with kid
aliases because maybe you have to help
somebody else with a good problem and
most of the time they don't have your
aliases so yeah but like there are cool
aliases to go to you on the terminal go
to your repository route its most of the
time I'm using git gr for get route and
then you go always to the repository
route and that's really
aliases all the integrate alias so I
don't have do to do two or three get
commands in a row I only execute one one
thing and we refine a lot of people say
to me yeah but I'm I really like the
gooey thing because I can see the log
and it's really nice and it has colors
and I see some lines and stuff like that
get lock is really really powerful on
the terminal and you can you can do
really cool things with good lock on the
terminal there are a lot of options you
can use like before or after you can get
commits from specific authors you can
check files that changed and stuff like
that and of course you can use crazy
aliases for for your gridlock for
example that's an alias I use it's get L
and what that does is it renders out a
really nice lock on the terminal what
you can do is you can color code
everything and configure what kind of
hashes you want to see and stuff like
that and in this case I'm also using - -
graph on the terminal and as you can see
you can see the the get graph and the
first on the left side there and if you
are following the guideline that you
only have like feature branch master
branch feature branch master branch it's
completely handable
on the terminal if you have like this
guitar hero thing it's it's not very
useful on the terminal another thing you
can can do with git lock is you can
search in it like with the regular less
commands you can just type slash and
your search term
and use n and uppercase n to the next or
previous finding that you that you
searched that's really handy and most of
the time that's much more difficult to
do in a GUI tool than on a terminal next
up is gits - mmm
anybody's used get stash before well
that's quite a lot okay so get stash is
mmm - if you want to most of the time if
you say okay I want to get up
upstream changes I want to do git pull
and get is telling you yeah I can't do
it because you did some changes over
there and I don't know what to do with
it please commit or stash so what did
what it means is it is telling you yeah
you have some changes and the upstream
has changes as well and I don't know how
to put those together and now obviously
you can commit them and let get to the
merge stuff but you're not quite happy
with that that chain those changes and
you don't want to commit to commit them
right now so what you can do is you can
stash them and what stash does is it
moves your changes away in some magical
place so you can type git stash and then
your changes are gone right there
vanished happily in the stash what you
can do now is you can say okay let's see
what's in my stash and now we have an
object in our stash and we can now get
our changes back so with kids - pop for
example we can get our changes back
execute git status and now our changes
are back
so what we can do we can stash them we
can pull changes from upstream and then
get our changes back from the stash so
we can get stash pop what that is doing
is it removes the item from the stash
and applies the changes but you can also
use git stash
apply and if you have multiple changes
in your stash you can pick the stash you
want to apply them and you can of course
drop certain things from your stash and
clean up this the stash but that's very
useful for example if you have an
application where you if you want to
debug the application you have to like
change three places you have to change
some conflict value and you have to add
some special parameters to it and yeah
multiple changes what you can do is you
can add these changes or make these
changes and then get stash them and
whenever you want a debug you can just
apply that stash and then these multiple
changes are done in your in your
application you can debug and then you
can run git stash again and you can or
get reset and remove the changes again
but whenever you need them you can get
them from your from your stash so that's
quite handy a lot of IDs are stashing on
default so if you're executing update in
JetBrains ide what they are doing if you
have changes they stash your changes
update and then we apply your your
changes and since the idea jet prints ID
does that automatically sometimes you
can end up with some weird kid state
like okay I want to reapply the stash
but it can't because we have conflicts
now and yeah and that's what what's
happening there
so then you have you can try to figure
it out a really nice thing about the
atomic commits I was talking about
earlier is if something bad happens like
so we are in our sin mode right we are
developing and kicking kicking features
out and somebody comes along and says
here's something bad happens right and
it's terrible enough that the bad thing
happened and we we can somehow fix it
but now the business is telling us okay
we have to know since when this problem
exists right so we had some customers
stuff that was not that that wasn't
working right and we have to know how
many customers we have to contact we
have to know exactly since when this
issue is in our code base or when when
it when it went to production so what we
can do is we have to investigate our
complete history and have to figure out
when this issue got introduced in our
code base so as we all know so the
business is coming saying okay we know
it wasn't it was working all right like
two months before right so we have some
point in time where we know this was
working and now we have to figure out
where the problem was introduced in our
code base so what we would do is we
would do the the binary search and we go
in somewhere into the middle and we'll
check okay is this working no it's here
it's bad right and then okay science
must be somewhere over there okay this
is working so it can be either this one
no no this is working so this is the
back home it right and of course we can
do that manually but the cool thing is
it has a tool for that and that's called
git bisect and what we can do is we can
say okay we want to start a bisect and
so we type git bisect start and then we
have to do with two things we have to
say to get this is the stuff where
everything worked and this is the point
in time where it it didn't work so in in
our state in our example the current
state the hats
that is not working so what we're doing
is we say git bisect bad and say okay
the Hat state is not working and then we
say okay get bisect good and we saw no
like in release version 2.0
it was good and we are getting the
commit hash and we're saying yeah this
this was good
what get is doing now is exactly doing
what where this was showing for before
on the slide right it's going to the
middle and then we check it we say no
this is still bad and it get checks out
the stuff and then we can we say okay
now we can test it and then caso hmm
okay did what this one is good and then
after a while it will tell you okay this
one was the commit that made everything
burn in this example right and here's
the advantage of doing atomic commits if
you're doing small commits the change
set that you did in this commit should
be very small and then you can easily
find the problem that caused the issue
right so now we really have to do we
type git bisect we set we want to end
our bisect one and then we are back to
the point where we started in our
current head state and that's quite nice
because we don't have to check out all
that stuff manually but we still have to
check our software manually so we still
have to do all that stuff and make check
if our application works and the cool
thing is if we have unit tests we can
say okay we do a bisect and we do the
same stuff and get we'll check out the
the same commit as before but what we
can do now is we can say okay let's run
our unit tests and then gates will
automatically validate the the return
value of our unit tests and so if our
unit has passed the commit will be
marked
good and if the unit has failed the
commit will be marked as bad so it
automatically checks out all our
revisions and will run the unit tests
and then will automatically determine
the commits that did the bad stuff right
so you don't have to do anything you can
say bisect unit tests go for coffee and
then come back and let me tell you where
the bad stuff happens in your software
so that's that's really really nice and
that's one more example of why you
should make sure that every commit works
because if you have a commit in your
history then maybe you have a syntax
error or something like this so I
couldn't even compile right then this
wouldn't work at all because it will
always fail because you can't execute
the unit tests if you're if you can't
compile your application or if you have
some other stuff that's that's not
working there so that's all from me
thank you and if you have any questions
feel free to ask
[Applause]
with git bisect run run do you have a
good strategy to run a new unit test
against all the old commits yes what you
have to do is so if you find a buck
normally there's no unit test for it
right because otherwise you would have
found the bug right much earlier what
you can't do is you can't write the unit
test into a into a file that's already
in your repository because if you commit
it and you check out an older version
the unit test isn't there so what you
have to do is you have to write the unit
test in a completely new file that's not
in your repository and just leave it
there the the unit tool should recognize
that file and it shouldn't care about
the file that's not in the repository
and if you found the bad commit you can
then move that unit test and to the
right file and commit it so this it's
yeah you have to you have to work around
that you can change the file that's in
you get repository so if it's a new unit
test you have to create a file that's
not on your repository but that works
what exactly does get run when you do
get run unit tests so what it does is
it's it's executing the binary and it's
evaluating the return value of that
binary so the exit code right so if if
the UNIX command is successful it
normally returns zero and if it's not
successful it's returning an exit called
higher than zero like 1 or whatever and
what git bisect 1 is doing it's
evaluating this exit code and if the
exit code is zero it will say ok it
everything worked so it should be a good
commit and if the exit code of the
command you run is hyoe 0 not 0 then it
will mark the commit as bad so you can
create you don't have to do unit tests
you can just write a script whatever you
want in your programming language in
bash or whatever that creates an exit
code for the failure scenario and a exit
code of zero if everything is fine so
that's another easy way to find the
issue if you don't have unit tests just
write a script that simulates the issue
and then you'll find what would I do if
I have spent two days bisecting the
Linux kernel and end up in a 3,000 line
merge commit is this game over or yeah
yeah have fun yeah of course I think
there's always like big projects and if
you and sometimes it's necessary to
change like 200 files at once but if you
have created an issue in this type of
commits it's really hard and there's no
easy way to answer or to handle it it's
it's yeah it's hard work to find the
issue sadly
much commit I think there's a good
chance that that merge commit has to
parents not just one so there are other
commits which could be run through B SEC
and search for them which are still good
and others which still fail so normally
you don't end up at a merge commit in a
be sick run yeah yeah any more questions
nope then thank you again and have a
nice afternoon
[Applause]
you